مخاوف وروسيه كبيره من فقدان السيطره على
الاجواء الاوكرانيه في ظل استمرار الدعم
الغربي لقياف للسيما بمنظومات الدفاع
الجويه وايضا المقاتلات الحربيه لذلك لا
شيء يشغل بال موسكو وقواتها سوى البحث عن
مواقع انتشار منظومه باتريوت الامريكيه في
اوكرانيا خصوصا بضواحي اكياف كون هذه
المنظومه الجويه الامريكيه تتركز لحمايه
العاصمه ما تطلب الدفع والزج بصواريخ
كنجال الروسيه المتطوره في تحقيق ما تسعى
اليه موسكو وهو تدمير بطاريات باتريات
اينما وجدت في اوكرانيا ليبقى الجو تحت
سيطرتها وفقا طبعا لما فسره مسؤول عسكري
غربيون لكن مشاهدينا استهداف هذه المنظومه
ليس بالامر السهل طبعا على القوات الروسيه
التي لجات في محاوله لتجنيد جواسيس داخل
مركز القياده للقوات الاوكرانيه لتدمير
هذه
الدفاعات وفقا طبعا لتقارير استخباراتيه
غربيه واوكرانيه هنا الدفاع الروسيه
بدورها اكدت انها مصره على تدمير كل سلاح
يمد فيه الغرب اوكرانيا مشيره طبعا الى ان
عمليه تدمير الباتريوت لا تستغرق وقتا
طويلا لان سرعه صواريخ كنجال تسمح لها
بالوصول الى منشات عسكريه ومنظومات دفاعيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بسرعه الضوء وفي
غضون دقائق وفقا للوصف الروسي لكن يبدو ان
المشكله الاكبر تتمثل بتحديد مواقع هذه
البطاريات لتدميرها وضربها بهذه الصواريخ
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات